مرتديا بذاته العسكريه وصل الرئيس
الاوكراني فولد ميرسي الى واشنطن في اول
زياره له خارجه اوكرانيا منذ بدء الحربه
الرئيس الامريكي يوجبايدن تعاهد لدى
استقبال جيلنسكي بالوقوف الى جانب
اوكرانيا مهما تطلب الامر
وبمساعدتها حتى تحقيق النصر وفي حين تم
الاعلان عن مساعدات جديده بنحو مليار
و850 مليون دولار لاوكرانيا تشمل منظومه
صواريخ بيت روت شدد ايضا على ان الهدف ليس
التصعيد
الجويه الدقيقه ستجمل حزمه المساعدات
بطاريات صواريخ التي ستتدرب عليها القوه
الاخرانيه في اطار الجهد المستمر لتعزيز
قدرات الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني سيستغرق
التدريب بعض الوقت ولكن بطاريته ستكون
بمثابه مهم لاوك في دفع العدوان الروسيه
عن نفسها
لم تقتصر على البيت الابيض متحدثا باللغه
الانجليزيه وجه رساله امتنان للمشرعين
والشعب الامريكي في خطاب امام جلسه مشتركه
للكونجرس بمجلس كما تناول الخطاب صمود
الاوكرانيين في الحرب بعكس التوقعات لكننا
زلينسكي شدد مخاطبا المشارعين بان دعمهم
بالغوا الاهميه ليس للتقدم في ساحه
المعركه بل لتحقيق النصر
او لدوله اخرى تسع روسيا للسيطره عليها
هذا صراع سيحدد العالم الذي سيعيش فيه
اولادنا واحفادهنا ولا يمكن تجميده هذا
الصراع او تجاهله
وفي الوقت الذي تم فيه زياده كم ونوع
السلاح الذي قدمته الولايات المتحده
لاوكرانيا منذ بدء الحرب بما في ذلك
الاعلان الاخير عن منظومه بيتريوت الا
نزلن في اوضح انه سيطلب المزيد
مهمه جدا وستمكن الاوكرانيين من وقف
الروسي من تدريب التحتيه وخصوصا المفاعلات
النوويه
بهذه الكلمات